[Music]
pornography is another one of your
interests in the book but it's not I
don't I don't celebrate to porn you know
I use it occasionally that's how I like
to look at it celebrate it unlike who
who's celebrating you'd be surprised a
lot of guys out there just now watching
with I do oh yeah yeah no I think you
got to be careful not to enjoy too much
you never want to you know if you're
about to watch porn and you do any
version of that yeah what do you you
know you're far gone yeah you know I
think that yeah I think when what you
perceived watching porn is you should
probably be working on something else
you know maybe you're at home alone
perhaps writing that novel or that
screenplay and you're just sitting there
and you have that moment of you're like
no God what am I thinking this isn't
gonna work out yeah I'm an idiot
youporn and that's when that's when you
do it yeah as a quick little uh what I'm
saying is that with the only time you
should watch porn is when you're falling
down the pit of self and the only thing
you can do to stop your fall is grab
hold of your own penis that's when you
watch porn
you want to write that down it's in here
it's written that it's written in the
deepest crevices of my brain right now
another good time is when everyone goes
to the grocery store
[Applause]
that's only something man with a family
consent he has a family and he has to
prepare differently than me right right
I don't think it's a I don't think it's
a great idea to watch too much porn
that's my point there's so much of it
out on the internet you need everything
it's not like when we were kids oh yeah
I tell you you're right I mean I think
some computers come with porn on them
now is that possible leave it that's how
they tell them you pop open a new
computer oh my god there's people having
sex right away yeah boy apples really
changed since Jobs died here so no but
like you think about it like when I was
14 13 14 year if there was if there was
a performance that you can get now like
then I mean I would never leave my room
my head would explode I just have a nub
my girlfriend she's in the dressing we
think this is making me look good
so no but like you remember when we were
kids you had to know the kid who had an
older brother or the weird dad you know
if you you know what I mean you got to
keep lookout in front of a bedroom why
he ripened for a mattress through a
mattress or or you had to find like one
page of a porno magazine under a bridge
with your friends brother you see my
brother used to get him out of dumpsters
we would look at corner that had like
potato peels and coffee grounds on
exactly was disgusting
yeah but you know that's why you're
aroused by potato peels now it was a
rare is like in the depression kid right
you'd find where you find it page with
your friends you need to argue who got
to take it home first and you have that
moment like oh that's how it works you
know and then like you go back you go
back to that same place like every day
for like a month to see if the rest of
the magazine magically showed up as if
there were porn trolls out distribute
for the sunrises more bridges yes yeah
but it's just so you got to be careful
with it cuz there's a lot out there it's
dangerous you don't wanna get porn head
horn head horn head you know what porn I
didn't know I don't well I can give you
the long version of the short version um
you better want a short version because
it was primarily a show for children
okay why there's a big analogy but that
would require me saying more than penis
and doing a hand motion that I probably
couldn't do here so if you can't what
have you done so far that's allowable
and so far
now you're censoring yourself wait but
wait you're like a dirty mind maybe
you've been gesturing down south to hold
noise you do the thing though I didn't
do the thing what do you think you know
that you know what can I do it up here
and get away with it
that just means your that just means
you're riding the subway
all right where you work on the ranch
and dinner's ready yeah
here's ready we gotta get to this clip
we got to get to this clip